[Music]
it's Friday March 6 2020 welcome back to
CBS this morning I'm Gayle King with
Anthony Mason and Tony to copal as the
corona virus spreads across the country
and around the world we are dedicating
this hour to the deadly outbreak now the
goal of our special we're calling it
corona virus of race to respond is to
provide critical information on how the
virus is being tracked and treated will
answer your pressing questions and let
you know how to protect yourself and
your family we have a team of reporters
around the world they'll share the
latest on infection numbers supply
shortages and the economic impact we
also have a panel of health experts who
will be answering your questions but
first a look at how we got here in a
special eye opener at 8:00 we've got
breaking news from China where the
corona virus outbreak took a very
frightening turn Rayman Ascencio left
Wuhan the epicenter of this outbreak we
got out earlier to take a look and an
officer ordered really yelled at us to
leave 240 Americans have left the
epicenter of China's coronavirus
outbreak a lot of people actually scared
mistakenly thinking that this flight was
arriving full of sick people remember
right now there's no vaccine in the near
future and there's no medication the
situation on the diamond print is
deteriorating frankly I have to tell you
now we're becoming quite afraid
unfortunately one person passed away
overnight we cannot make predictions as
to how many cases but we will have more
the possible outbreak of this virus is
not happening in a major city instead in
this leafy suburb we are definitely
going to see more cases we have not been
testing as they have in other parts of
the world now what does he chair in the
room do you have your stethoscope in
your purse I do feel my forehead Vietnam
is out with an insanely catchy PSA to
spread awareness about the corona virus
it's not what's great about music guys
it even when you don't know the words
you guys the tune and it's catchy but it
makes this little scary thing a little
lighter to deal with it
this morning's eye-opener is presented
by Toyota let's go places
welcome back to CBS s era this is a
special hour for us because we begin
with what we know about the corona virus
Barona viruses attacked the respiratory
system and this cover this corona virus
causes a disease called ko bid 19 now
most cases are mild and similar to the
flu or a cold the symptoms can include a
fever coughing and shortness of breath
they can appear two days or even two
weeks after you are exposed in just over
two months more than ninety-eight
thousand cases have been reported
worldwide the virus has killed more than
3300 people but more than 55,000
patients who had the virus have now
recovered the most severe cases have
been in older people and patients with
pre-existing medical conditions right
now scientists believe the virus spreads
between people in close contact that's
within about six feet of one another
public spaces are being sanitized in
hopes of containing the virus you can
get it from an infected person's cough
or sneeze or possibly by touching
something with the virus on it like a
door handle and then touching your face
the corona virus has spread to six
continents in just three months it was
first detected in December in Wuhan
China where it had previously only been
discovered in animals but jumped to
people from there the virus spread
quickly infecting dozens and forcing the
Chinese government to publicly declare
an output
and that outbreak soon stretched across
all of mainland China and then spread to
neighboring countries including Japan
Thailand and South Korea across the
Pacific on that very same day it
appeared in Washington State that is the
first known case in the United States by
February 5th the virus was on board the
diamond Princess cruise ship docked at
the time in Yokohama Japan of the 3,700
passengers on board that ship the virus
infected 706 of them eventually American
passengers were brought home to military
bases here in the US and the virus
unfortunately hitched a ride with at
least 46 of them
meanwhile the virus landed in Iran no
clue as to how it got there it also
exploded in Italy 124 cases became 888
cases that is the largest outbreak to
date outside of Asia Germany Britain
Croatia France and Spain have also
reported cases all out all throughout
Europe and then also in the southern
hemisphere Brazil Nigeria Ecuador and
South Africa cases there all told 89
countries worldwide are now reporting
cases and here in the United States
there are 21 states reporting at least
one case of the corona virus and that
leads us to today one of those states is
New York Megillah ver is in one of the
nation's busiest transportation hubs New
York City's Penn Station Magna computer
commuters there seemed concern
Anthony good morning they tell me that
they are definitely thinking about it
but as you can see they're still going
about their daily routine I commute an
hour a day by bus and subway and I can
tell you that I have seen more people
using hand sanitizer here in Penn
Station more than 650,000 people pass
through here every day that's a lot of
people in packed quarters as coronavirus
fears spread cases doubled to 22 in New
York State Thursday and more than 2,700
people are being monitored now
nationwide there are at least 230
confirmed cases of corona virus at least
12 deaths 11 of those in Washington
State
now those fears are creating a rush on
hand
sanitizers masks and cleaning supplies
sending sales up an estimated eight
hundred and seventeen percent store
shelves are empty across the country we
went to a supply company in New Jersey
where employees are working overtime to
keep up with demand the company's owner
says it's hard to restock because many
of the products are made in China cargo
ships aren't the only ones being kept
from our shores now for all of these
people traveling by rail Amtrak tells us
they are cleaning more trains and
stations and used a more disinfectant
gal all right Meg thank you very much
our Asia correspondent Ramey
innocencio has reported on this outbreak
from across a region first in January
from the virus epicenter in Wuhan China
then from South Korea that was in
February now in March he's in Japan for
a meet Tokyo let's talk about that first
it's usually a bustling city what's it
like now
[Music]
gaile good morning I'm at the famous
Shibuya crossing think of it as Tokyo's
version of Times Square really one of
the world's busiest intersections right
behind me now up to 2,500 people cross
this thoroughfare every single time
these lights change and if you can
believe it this Friday night right here
this is actually relatively peaceful now
here in Japan more than 300 people have
been confirmed to have coronavirus
unfortunately at least six people have
now died but the interesting thing is
that only about 900 people each day
actually get tested for the virus now
that really truly pales in comparison to
the country just west of us that of
course is South Korea where about 10,000
people that's right 10,000 people get
tested every single day there so far
South Korea has more than 6,000
confirmed cases that's the most for any
country outside of China but the death
rate get this is relatively lower and
only about 0.7 percent now that could be
thanks to innovative measures like
drive-through testing you heard that
right
where medical workers decked out in
protective clothing actually screen
drivers who get to stay behind the
wheels of their cars now earlier I spoke
to Sharon proffered she's an American
teacher in Daegu where most of South
Korea's infections are happening she
told me she actually feels safer there
than the United States
what can the u.s. learn from what's
happening where you are I think
transparency is a huge deal I think
having being more prepared for potential
outbreaks I don't think America is
prepared and Japan now says that
starting this Monday they are going to
be quarantine any traveler coming from
China or South Korea for the 14 days
that they are still in this country and
of course looking ahead to this summer
don't forget Tokyo is host of the Summer
Olympics that starts in July just about
three and a half months from now they
say that preparations are still
continuing at least for now Tony now it
is Ram you know Senseo in Tokyo force
ramie thank you very much Italy was the
first European country to ban flights
from China but that did not stop the
virus from ballooning out of control
there Charlie d'Agata is in Rome forest
where the Italian government faces a
massive challenge okay right away let's
get to those numbers overnight the
largest single-day increase since this
outbreak began there are now nearly 39
hundred cases 148 people have died we're
outside
Italy's number one Hospital for
infectious diseases and you might just
be able to make out those silver tents
behind me that's essentially a triage
and you see them outside hospitals
especially in the north which has been
hardest hit and this is where people
that may have the infection can be
treated and looked after without
spreading the virus to the rest of the
hospital across the country schools and
universities have been closed Italians
had actually been urged to keep some
distance from one another which
obviously doesn't come naturally in a
country like this this is also home to
Europe's oldest population the elderly
have been advised to stay indoors for
now what you don't see out on the
streets is a bunch of tourists across
the globe hotel cancellations are up to
more than 70% in Italy is at the top of
that table Gayle all right Charlie
d'Agata reporting from Rome thank you or
dr. Tara and her ULA's here with the
lessons that the u.s. can learn from how
other countries are responding to this
outbreak Tara good morning sometimes I
wonder do they know something we don't
when we see they shut down their whole
schools or restaurants are empty but
let's talk about that drive-by program
what can we learn from that what impact
does it really have so this was really
ingenious and so creative and you know
South Korea took a lesson from what
happened with their experience with MERS
back in 2015 where they really were not
prepared and so in in this a you're able
to basically drive up have a sample
taken within ten minutes you're not
exposing others to potential infection
and this gives you really a broad big
picture of the disease and that's what
you need you're picking up a lot more
cases and what that allows you to do is
get a more accurate case fatality rate
so you're screening more people an
additional allows you to really isolate
where the infection is coming from so
you can better control it and it also
allows you to get treatment to people
faster so that broad-based screening is
a really big deal we don't have enough
test kits according to vice president
pence how do we learn from other
countries to better manage our response
here well we need to start learning from
other countries and really speed is the
critical thing you know we know that
even in general medicine
the quicker you pick up on a disease the
quicker you can treat it and deal with
it and that is also the case with
epidemics and pandemics and so one of
the other things that other countries
have done a good job at is this concept
of social distancing so not congregating
in mass areas where you could
potentially get exposed you know in
South Korea they have a marketing
campaign aware they're saying you know
hold on let's not get social you know so
we have a lot to learn
all right Tara thanks
concerns about the coronavirus have
hammered stock markets around the world
the SARS outbreak in 2003 costs the
global economy an estimated 40 billion
dollars now some predict coronavirus
will do even more damage Carter Evans
shows us what may be the first major
sign in the u.s. of the spreading
economic contagion the Port of Los
Angeles is the largest in the United
States
40% of all shipped imports enter the
country here or next door in Long Beach
but now it's unusually quiet normally
Carter you would see about 10 to 12 very
large container ships working here at
the port every day none of that is
happening right now that's right and the
reason is that 40 vessel sailings have
been cancelled thus far we're a leading
indicator for the economy gene seroka is
executive director of the port he says
quarantine Xin China have factories
shutting down fewer products means less
cargo to ship
so this is going to impact everyone yes
it will it's a conversation of national
significance that drop in traffic is
slowing jaw burnings at the port which
is responsible for more than 10 percent
of employment throughout Southern
California but its impact could be felt
around the country these dividers is
more of an economic disaster than Isaac
Larian heads up mga entertainment the
company behind popular toys like brats
and lol surprise dolls so you've got the
number 10 selling toy in the entire
world I have number one and number ten
and number two a number four and they're
all sold out I would field that by some
estimates China produces 85% of the
world's toys the eighth biggest import
that usually comes through this port but
with their factories only operating at
40 percent capacity
products might start disappearing from
US store shelves if these things doesn't
come under control the next two to three
weeks it is going to affect so what is
toys
consumer electronics whether is that or
all of these things are going to get
affected
representatives from the automotive
industry and television manufacturers
tell CBS News they're closely monitoring
supply chains while a footwear trade
group says the footwear industry is
seeing an impact on supply and sales
from the coronavirus how is this going
to impact your bottom line maybe
hundreds of million multiply that by all
the businesses around the u.s. that rely
on this port and the numbers become
staggering this will be billions of
dollars worth of impact so people can
expect to pay higher prices because of
the inactivity here right now because
the supply is not coming in as fast as
you and I would like to buy our goods
for CBS this morning Carter Evans Los
Angeles CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here with what the
economic impact of the coronavirus could
mean for you good morning Jill we've
seen really a stock market really
unsettled extremely unsettled how
significant is the risk of a recession
right now well you know right now
economists are not calling for a
recession and the OECD said global
growth could actually be cut in half
because of the coronavirus from 2.9
percent to one and a half percent here
in the US I speak to a lot of economists
they say we think growth in the United
States could go from say around 2% to
one and a half percent as is however
they are increasing their odds of a
recession in 2022 50/50 and that's a big
jump from where we were just six weeks
all right so that's a big change
companies are going to be adjusted what
a regular people do to prepare well I
think if you look at like what you
really should do right now it's about
those old habits that we want you to
have we want you to try to take any
extra money and put it in a safe place
an emergency reserve fund we've always
talked about six to twelve months of
your living expenses in a safe place
if you are still employed and we still
have a vibrant job market right now
we're gonna get a jobs report out and
we're gonna have good numbers there the
thing is if you still have a job and
you've got cash flow
don't go spend it on stuff necessarily
but pay down some debt maybe you got
some credit card debt take care of
yourself build yourself a little
fortress Jill always a voice of reason
try Thank You Jill Schlesinger we'll be
right back
[Music]
welcome back to CBS this morning in our
special hour coronavirus a race to
respond so our goal this morning is this
to inform you about what we know where
we're headed and how to protect yourself
and your family the virus spreads we are
starting to hear first-hand accounts of
people directly affected including
passengers who were quarantined on the
diamond Princess cruise ship for me the
virus felt like a common cold my wife
and I get Valentine's Day quarantined on
the diamond princess together I'm
feeling fine I had a high fever of 103
plus I've had a dry cough if I wasn't
contagious I would have been back at
work the next day the corona virus swept
through the ship I ended up testing
positive relatively early on in the
quarantine and I was removed from the
ship and placed in a hospital in
downtown Tokyo where I spent exactly
three weeks my experience was thankfully
very mild there's no reason to panic
it's just a sickness and it will run its
course as the virus spreads here in the
u.s. we brought together a panel of
health experts to answer your questions
CBS News medical contributor you know
her well dr. taryn arul is back with us
we're also joined by Michael osterholm
director of the Center for infectious
disease research and policy at the
University of Minnesota he knows a lot
and dr. van Gupta he's a respiratory
specialist in global health policy
expert welcome doctors I want to start
with you Michael can we just talk about
the ship for a second what do you think
when you see that it is a cruel human
experiment why we know the cruise ships
facilitate transmission just by the air
circulation and the inner cabins and the
the principal and the diamond princess
was proof in putting of that and every
cruise ship where we have this where you
keep people out to sea it's just a
matter of time before many of them
getting ill we've got to get them off
the ship get them on land you can
quarantine them there if you want to do
that but get them off the ship let's
talk about the rest of us who aren't on
ships because I'm wondering how scared
you should be I had always thought many
people think if you haven't been to
Italy China South Korea Italy or any of
the affected countries and you haven't
come in contact with any of those people
that you're you're pretty
okay you know right now we have pretty
much a homogeneous viral reactor around
the world music they're not illegally
it's not it's it's what we see knew what
happened we predicted a month ago that
we would suddenly see activity pickup in
the United States today Seattle has as
many cases as many other of the
countries that we've mentioned they're
having a problem and we're gonna have
more Seattle's around the country in
just the next few days to weeks so it's
you have to now just like seasonal
influenza you have to assume that this
is everywhere right now and anyone could
potentially be infected that way so
terror in terms of testing should you
only get tested if you have symptoms
should everybody should be tested what's
what support of the parameters here yeah
I think it's an interesting question and
certainly this there was a change this
past week and so basically that change
said that anyone can get tested with the
permission of their doctor but what
we're looking at are people who have the
symptoms we know are associated with
kovin 19 which is fever shortness of
breath cough in that if you have those
symptoms you should speak to your doctor
and let the doctor really get an
assessment of your clinical picture what
your travel history or exposure history
might be and then make a decision as to
whether you should be tested and at that
point you know you will be either sent
to a hospital or you know at some point
have it done in the clinic when those
lab tests become available dr. Gupta
what what does the corona virus actually
do to your body any point of entry to
the body the sinuses the oral pharynx
your gastrointestinal tract what it does
is it invades the lining of those
cavities and causes local inflammation
and that's when you have symptoms that's
when you have shortness of breath that's
when you have coffee you have a wrong
runny nose is that those are and we're
also seeing you sometimes have GI
symptoms as well and so that is that is
what's happening at the cellular level
you always have symptoms do always so
one of the but one of the interesting
dynamics here is that we're seeing
potentially asymptomatic transmission
here where people are not actually
demonstrating classic symptoms of coughs
Orton's of breath fever but they're able
to transmit the disease I will say one
thing on testing one of the struggles we
have and everything Tara said is
absolutely correct is we don't have we
don't know these emergency tests that
are coming that are just cleared by the
FDA who knows how they function in the
fields we have no idea we don't know if
they're gonna
you're saying what we hope they do and I
hope they're better than what was
initially deployed four weeks ago to the
states but who's to say how they're
gonna actually function in the field are
they getting me highly sensitive enough
we hope that's the key piece that's the
unknown Michael are we prepared for this
to spread across the country well we're
prepared in the sense that we know it's
coming and we know that our health care
facilities are going to have a major
increase in load we that's not an issue
of debate what is a concern is how
prepared are we at the healthcare level
in particular are we prepared we're not
we we have 45,000 beds in this country
for intensive care medicine and any one
given day they are filled can you can
you get this and it you get can you get
this not know you have it and recover
without being treated yes in fact the
vast majority of what we now know is is
that in the first day of your infection
where you're actually putting virus now
you may not even have symptoms that we
just heard from dr. Gupta but then we
know that over the next three to five
days you have this rest upper
respiratory for infection that just like
the flu type of picture for some reason
a large risk is there for people who are
over age 55 60 above underlying health
problems for the virus then getting into
the lungs and then causing the
additional problem
the vast majority people will never
experience that they're just gonna have
those first couple of days of
respiratory symptoms but they can't get
through it and they won't eat they won't
even be treated and they'll be fine but
they might affect infect others dr.
Gupta we have a question from a viewer
in Minnesota Laurie let's listen to that
I would like to know how long the virus
lives on the various surfaces it's such
a good question and I think what we have
what we know now we have studies that's
oh so it depends on ambient temperature
number one and then on the surface and
so depending on the temperature if it's
a 70 degrees you can see you can see
fomites basically the virus particles
live on surfaces like paper or steel up
to up to anywhere from two hours to nine
days but if it's ambient if it's safe 60
to 70 degrees longer lifespan that's
hotter or colder or sort of let's man
Michael another viewer asked a question
should we be limiting our air travel and
gatherings of large numbers of people
South by Southwest is scheduled for next
week right now it's still on those kind
of gatherings you
today if here's someone who is over age
55 you're someone who has underlying
health problems I would say don't put
yourself at risk and being in those
large gatherings younger age populations
have seen very little serious illness in
fact no one in Korea under age 30 has
died in China only 2.1 percent of the
cases were in people 19 years of age or
younger so again I think we have to
start looking carefully one of the areas
that were very concerned about school
closings mostly today the illness is
going to be in adults and if it's not in
kids should we be closing schools well
maybe yes if they're shredding the virus
that are getting sick I mean getting
infected not sick and shutting the virus
and we should so yeah at this point just
and seeing if four people with
underlying health problems always a real
I think important issue Tara we want to
do a quick reality check on some of the
things that we've been hearing about the
first face mask which they're getting a
lot of attention do face masks actually
protect you from the virus no right and
we've been trying to make this point
loud and clear the search in general
tried to make this point stop buying
face masks so the surgical masks that
you see everybody walking around with
are not able to prevent those viral
particles from getting to you they can
go around they're not you know fitted to
your face appropriately the n95
respirator masks that the healthcare
professionals use are meant to keep out
95% a very small part don't save them
for the health you should Michael is
this more or less contagious than the
traditional flu you know this is just
like influenza in every way possible and
I the way I describe it it's like trying
to control the wind you know we and
anyone that would suggest trying to stop
a seasonal flu year by trying to control
us somehow it would be laughed out of
the room it's really about either
vaccine for fluid this one we don't have
a vaccine so we're pretty much at the
whims of this kind of respiratory
transmission dr. Gupta we've been
talking about people but what about pets
I mean this came from an animal can I go
back to an asking about sense there's
the case of the of the dog in Hong Kong
I believe that tested weakly positive
for the virus what I can say and the
evidence that exists today suggests no
hmm you cannot actually acquire
coronavirus from a pet I think we'll
wait it's a wait-and-see approach though
because we just don't know enough
information but right now the evidence
suggests no what a hand size
so everywhere what product should we be
using if any alcohol-based hand rub
which you know the one that we all
talked about is Parral but there are a
number of them on the market and they do
help and they not only help with this
but we have a lot other infectious
diseases the three of us are worried
about besides influenza and that helps a
lot with those two yeah what about the
liquor cabinet at home it is a Friday
without watch anything away great public
health no siege on alcohol that way is
not so I'll call in moderation somebody
Lysol - - all right so the EPA just
released a five-page letter that lists
all the potential products that can be
used against kovin 19 and they've been
shown to be effective against viruses
that are even harder to kill than covin
19 Lysol is one of those products listed
Elora Clorox
exactly we know that the Cova 19 viruses
surround it it's an enveloped virus by a
fatty layer that can be broken down
easily by these designs
saravana and Michael thank you all very
much very helpful
along with a growing number of
infections the corona virus is spreading
fear and discrimination against
asian-americans restaurants and other
businesses in cities from New York to
California have reported big drops in
sales we're also learning about reports
of racist incidents at hotels and
bullying of Asian American students we
shashank visited a struggling Chinese
restaurant in New York City Weezer what
did you learn
oh good morning Anthony it is clear that
Asian Americans are facing
discrimination over a disease that does
not discriminate the CDC says Asians are
not more likely to contract or spread
coronavirus than anyone else
politicians are now working to combat
racism but one restaurant owner we spoke
to said the damage is done
how has coronavirus impacted your
business
tremendous king lambs family has owned a
popular New York City dim sum restaurant
for more than four decades he's been
through SARS you've been through swine
flu is coronavirus different when it
comes to business yes under vain you
talk about someone it's mindful and h1n1
we didn't feel anything at all Lam says
he's lost 1.5 million dollars and
business is down around 50% what do you
think the reason is the reason is
because Chinese started the the coma
virus but it's a scare to get infected
by Chinese people and they think Chinese
people have erratic Chinese rises and
it's not just at restaurants last month
the man posted videos on Facebook that
appear to show employees at two hotels
in Indiana turning him away so no agents
there
why's that
because the virus CBS News reached out
to the alleged victim but did not hear
back
Windham hotels and resorts which owns
both hotels said in a statement they are
deeply troubled by these incidents as
they are not reflective of our values or
our expectations of franchisees and
they're treating this matter seriously
the racism has also surfaced in
classrooms in Madison Wisconsin
school officials say there's been
comments made toward Asian students and
they're working to stop those
responsible in really seizing that
moment to educate that student so they
you know understand that their words
have meaning and can be hurtful it's not
just in the u.s. Asians around the world
have reported discrimination linked to
coronavirus he shouted I don't want your
coronavirus in my country Jonathan Mok
is a student from Singapore studying in
London he told the BBC he was walking
down the street last week when four
people attacked him she's such a serious
problem that has plagued us for a very
long time there's also been apparent
attacks in New York City posted on
social media
Peter ku is a councilman in Flushing
Queens a predominantly Asian
neighborhood asian-americans are just
like other Americans I was in other
major cities across the country
politicians have tried to combat racism
and Miss information there's been a lot
of xenophobia against folks who are part
of our Asian community showing support
at rallies and by dining in restaurants
but Lam worries the road to recovery is
the long one it sounds like Corona is
crippling businesses its booming
community it is do you think the damage
is done the damage is already done it's
already done
Liam Toros business continues to drop
every day and he doesn't think they have
seen the worst of it yet the New York
State Assembly just passed a measure
that allows the governor to direct
emergency funds to small businesses
impacted by coronavirus noise I agree
with that signed fight the virus not the
people who have it
that's all right it's very important
that you're doing this story though we
should to let people know that this is
happening and that it really is not okay
well the community feels like you know
they're fighting to diseases exactly the
disease of corona but also bigotry and I
really feel for those young kids
especially who are Americans that are
being made to feel like the other yeah
Lygia thank you very much thank you
before we go our goal in this special
coronavirus the race to respond is to
provide you with critical information
about the virus and how you can protect
yourself our doctor Tara Narula is back
with some final tips beginning with one
that's been a kind of an undercurrent to
this whole hour which is don't panic
right an undercurrent for everyone I
mean every patient I see every family
member I talk to so there is a low level
of anxiety throughout the country right
now and I think the key to kind of
regaining a little bit of control and
less anxiety is information there's
power and information and accurate
information and transparency so one of
the great resources is for individuals
to go to the CDC website there is so
much there that's up-to-date and
accurate so we've talked a lot about all
these products flying off the shelves
what should again what should people
actually buy I know I went yesterday I
could not find anything so it's
important to keep first and foremost
prescription drugs okay if you have to
be in your home for 14 days you want to
have at least a two-week supply of your
prescription medications or other
essential medications non-perishable
foods diapers formula anything that you
might need if you are required to stay
at home and one last tip that my
seven-year-old daughter loves cuz she
loves making slime is you can make your
own hand sanitizer 2/3 a cup of rubbing
alcohol 1/3 of a cup of aloe vera gel
and a little bit of essential oil and
there you have it if you can't find
Purell very so as long as it's over 60%
alcohol that's the important part
Thank You Tara Tara will continue and
answer your questions about the corona
virus on Facebook live right after the
show just head over to our CBS this
morning Facebook page to join that
conversation that'll do it for a special
hour coronavirus the race to respond
we'd like to have a great weekend as dr.
Tara said don't panic
be prepared Monday be prepared